is preparing for the wars nevada law
enforcement officers say they'll be
ready as possible thanks to this new
training center victoria saha joined
state senators for a tour earlier today
this tactical training facility has
everything law enforcement would need to
prepare for real life scenarios their
newest project will be making a
makeshift school here in their newest
building
being prepared for any type of critical
incident is crucial when every second
matters
at metro's newest reality-based training
center senators catherine cortez masto
and jackie rosen secured three million
dollars in federal funding to help buy
technology training equipment and other
resources ensuring that our law
enforcement officers that our
firefighters that our first responders
emt
everyone has the
tools that they need and the ability to
actually train
and prepare for whatever may come their
way to keep our community safe we never
know what's around the corner both
senators made it clear they stand by law
enforcement to create any training
necessary we want you to return home
safely
every night
that's why we have centers like this and
just friday we've learned officers
waited to enter the school classroom in
texas undersheriff christopher darcy
says a training facility like this helps
prepare his team to respond immediately
when we respond that we will enter the
structure so we have an entire section
that's devoted to training all of our
officers on that they have continued to
reflect and learn from the one october
shooting that took 60 lives during a
concert in las vegas that way we'll do
it better if it should happen again
those who assisted in friday's tour says
they are confident they have everything
they need in this facility to respond
immediately to a situation to help keep
our community safe whether you're living
in southern nevada or just visiting here
victoria zaha live local now